hotspot smart
[Musik]
ihr fragt euch wahrscheinlich einlud
warum glaubst du ich trete jetzt von
auswärts 3 2 1
als sechser gepasst für mich wirklich
gut machen wir besorgen
münster
ich habe mich gut vielleicht sogar aus
halte dieses autos bild wie frag dich
wahrscheinlich hält luca warum guckst du
gerade schon wieder was ist sagte intel
habe das mitbekommen ich habe mir vor
einigen wochen einen splitter in meinen
daumen gehauen perfekt haben diese
dennoch fed geschnitten hat den fand ich
dann vor einem monat genau die op und
der arzt meinte jana eineinhalb wochen
hast du eigentlich keine schmerzen mehr
und ist im monat vergangen und hat immer
noch schmerzen und einem finger und geht
man hier ganz abdecken was damit es
durch die kleinste parklücken die ich je
gesehen habe
[Musik]
man kann nicht gegen juden und basken
ich wohne doch in der innocent ja straße
ist nicht einfach mein vertrauen
entspannt überschneiden also dass selbst
das mein fahrrad hey warum kommt man
leichter machen wir kurzen herbst ja
also sonst nur die aufmachen ohne dass
ich mein komplettes parkett zerstören
das kann ich auf jeden fall
wahrscheinlich spiele zu runde vier
spielen ist als revanche köln gegen
paris ja vielleicht drei minuten später
[Applaus]
ich glaub du kommst du nicht aus auf den
vorgang seien von breite von den
schultern von drei davon schirm
[Musik]
jack bauer
er will wissen über die heute recht
gebrochen
großes fenster
grün
steht
günstig united colors of benetton
[Musik]
ich bin eigentlich da wo soll ich den
leuten bisschen hamburg zeigen rathaus
ende noch mehr lernen wurden später von
quoten die nennt man die hauptstadt von
süd afrika bestätigend habe ich gerne
mein haus mein ratschlag bekommen
zum glück haben die überhaupt nicht
wieder adventskalender und mein gott ist
das gar nichts
[Musik]
geschmeckt
willst du den zuschauern zeigen dass die
gold im oktober und mit 24 rp mobil
adventskalender weniger geld hätte man
etwas von helm kaufen und er ist sogar
gemacht für draußen also ich sag mal
warum skitag los wenn der leute dran
denn hier hat man einfach einen
traditionellen bäcker und daneben
und da alles was ich brauche ja eher
willst dann instagram pushen in meinem
blog laser luca in mexiko weiter kocht
muss ich als paar wochen im keller
bringt im leben geht der kampf wieder
vorstudie grad
hey ludwig kamera hierhin gekommen ohne
dass das schon im rahmen war es matschig
[Musik]
also ich dachte ich hätte mich jeder
eingesperrt und hier wird live dabei die
ich meine heizung komplett zerstört das
kommt aus der kamera nicht so richtig
über aber meiner musik dazu viel rauch
weil max ihr komisches cd-kauf max wo
bist du max wieder die kamera alter hier
steht der rauch max wobei es so sein
dass er davon dass und rinder für den
koch und ich stehe hier
max hat rinder für die für 40 euro
gekauft was jetzt zweimal schlecht war
und länder es ist das einfach
die beiden sind sich sicher auch
schlecht ist ich bin mir hundert prozent
sicher dass wenn man dieses ding hier
ist dass man kotzen und scheißen würden
mit lohan probiert das gleiche kritiken
nicht mehr halten
wir haben beides probiert und wir finden
es relativ normal ist auch erst 20 euro
wenn wir gerade ein brisantes thema und
zwei unterhalten uns darüber auch wir in
duschen pissen oder nicht klettert dann
komm endlich sein erstmals krone